all right up next is gonna be Brianna in
Utah hi Brianna how are you good how are
you better than I deserve
how can I help ya so my question is I am
on baby steps number two and when we
started this journey me and my husband
we agreed on it we sat down did our
budget together but now it comes to my
spouse has been taking money out of our
checking account I'll go to buy
groceries with my envelope and there's
money taken out of there when I asked
him about it he just brings up oh well
you know I make most of the money in the
household so if I need to buy something
I'm just gonna go ahead and do it so
basically my question what should I do
you need marriage counseling okay
because your husband made an agreement
with his wife and then he lied he broke
the agreement if I tell my wife I'm
gonna do something and then I don't do
it I broke my agreement with the person
on the light on that out of all the
people on the planet that I should keep
my agreements with what if he signed a
contract in business and then just said
oh you know what I decide I don't wanna
do that it's the same thing in it mm-hmm
I mean cuz you feel lied to and betrayed
on betrayed it's not about the money
it's like he's throwing his weight
around like I'll make all the money what
a bunch of crap really I mean what a
bunch of control-freak crap I mean what
if I did that with Sharon Ramsey you
think that he'll really want me to put
up with that no no I've made all the
money in my house for 35 years and and
we have a budget that we agreed to and
we have a net worth and we have money I
do not come in and go I make all the
money I will do whatever I want that
would fly with that hillbilly woman
about 30 seconds and she would go off on
me and rightfully so you
follow me so I mean basically your
problem is is that he agreed to
something and then broke his word right
right that's what's bothering you if he
had come in instead and said hey you
know there's something over here I
really want to do let's talk about
adjusting the budget let's look at this
you might have considered that that
would be a reasonable way to approach
this hey I know we looked at the budget
and laid it out but I got this thing I
wanna do let's look at adjusting the
budget and I'd really like to pull this
off and you look at and you go yeah okay
I'll go with that
that wouldn't be a problem and it might
have accomplished exactly the same thing
instead he like
steals the money out of the food
envelope really here how old is this
child he just turned 25 today oh okay
well it's time for him to be a man now
and keep his word and so I'm picking at
him and I'm being I'm having a little
fun with you okay good but the truth is
it's breaking your heart because your
man is acting like a bully yeah that's
the truth because he's not keeping his
word men keep their word mm-hmm and so
you need to call him out on that to say
listen I don't care who makes the most
money we share everything here we have
an income we have a budget we have a
plan and if you don't agree to that we
now have a problem and we are going to
sit down with the pastor and have some
marriage counseling and that that's what
I would do if I were in your shoes so I
think you call him out on it I just did
in front of a whole bunch of people like
millions of people just heard me do it
so you know but you can't you know
here's the thing you guys aren't going
to prosper in your marriage in this
situation because you're really getting
frustrated and angry and hurt by him
breaking his word and couples that do
not work together on their money have a
very low success rate almost all the
people we sent we meet that get out of
debt and become everyday millionaires
the vast majority of them work together
like 90 percent there's almost no one
overcomes the
becomes wealthy there's almost no one
overcomes this and has a high-quality
marriage it doesn't work that way so you
got it you got to work this through and
sometimes it's okay sit down the
marriage counselor and have somebody be
the referee and throw a flag and blow
the whistle and like I was just doing
because I was definitely blowing the
whistle just in hey thank you for the
call